okay so this is the question we're
looking at now it's really more hard to
solve it's great it's really beautifully
simple okay
but I want to show you the the beats
that I go through as I am as I actually
write out my working okay so have a look
what where else to do is find this under
inside that V over there
okay so the first thing you should do is
write down I'll squeeze right down the
premium or your after that's the very
first thing you should do okay so I want
to find me so I'm gonna put it front and
center that was the first step right the
printing or you're after the second step
it is and even though you didn't I'm not
asking you to draw a diagram maybe you
want to probe like a rough one for
yourself at least for the first couple
of questions I want to identify what's
the leg that corresponds to the one I'm
off done okay so let me set that again
step one write down the printing we want
step to work out which is the
corresponding length it's 12 okay so
what I'm doing is I'm saying okay
there's a proportion of ratio between
these two and each should be the same as
another proportion another ratio I can
see in the question so step one was
right down the per new step two was
matching up the s 1e was matching up
with the corresponding leg step three is
to say hey look this should be another
ratio that's going in the same direction
so I can compare these two okay
so I'm going to write that down tree
okay yes sure
so what I did was I said okay here's
what I want
he's what corresponds to what I want so
these two guys are kind of like married
together okay but to find out how they
relate to each other I've got to use
this relationship down here so I'm going
to say what step three is what's the
other piece of information in the
question that help me evaluate that so
step one two here and here's step 3 okay
now this is not hard
let's just go ahead and life is out just
to save you a bit of time I've already
got a number I don't need this okay
here's the answer that I've come up with
okay now it's tempting to just sort of
write that down immediately okay but
there's a fourth step there's a four
step after you write down your premium
wall see what length matches to it and
then get something which corresponds to
both of those you've got a look at this
thing and a player since we've talked
that sense checks before okay does this
number make sense does it look
reasonable okay
now come back to your diagram okay come
back have a look at this before you put
pen to paper when you looked you knew
that they had to be smaller than 12 do
you see why you see why because this is
the smallest shape to the bigger shape
right so you're making this comparison
ten point two it kind of does fit what I
expect okay
now the most common error to get most
common are things did wrong is to say
this talk is to going like this what
have I done wrong
why do I fit the wrong way what thing
about misunderstood in order to have
this upside down hmm I've gone this way
for the first ratio and then I've gone
the opposite direction for the second
ratio okay here's the thing though
right okay so what countries not before
me can someone find out what it is okay
now when you have a look at this as a
number it's not like this is you
ridiculous number but your common sense
should tell you why something has gone
wrong right go back interpret cuz like
this side smaller and now this sides
bigger
I can't the proportions haven't been
preserved so clearly I've made some
simple numerical things you just go back
and check Thanks
okay so the one is in rare is wrong
can't because this length is too long
this legs should be shorter than 12 it's
not bigger question
I guess my question for you would be but
why does that explain why the answer is
whatever don't come in just a second
okay so can we review I set up like five
times
step 1 what step 1 find the printer will
write down step 2 find one matches to
what corresponds step 3 you just read a
ratio so you need to write down a ratio
and that will be equivalent to that you
can see it on the diagram last step
after you got our top sense check write
how the look is a reasonable does it
matter with what you expect